steve kaufman here um
you know there are two questions that i
receive very often
one is
what do you think of studying more than
one language at the same time
and the second one is how long does it
take to learn a language
in so far as the first one is concerned
i think it's a matter of personal
preference
i cannot study more than one language at
a time because it's such a tremendous
commitment
almost emotionally that i can't see
myself doing it for two languages i can
dabble i can refresh languages that i
already know
but in terms of
taking on a language
a new language for me it's a total
commitment other people study three or
four languages so it's entirely a matter
of of what your preferences are and how
much time you have so that's the first
one i think there is no simple answer
it's what you like to do
the other big question is how long does
it take to learn a language
um you know it reminds me of when i was
in high school once
uh we had had a history exam or a
history test and the teacher was very
angry because it was it had been very
poorly done and the teacher came into
the classroom and and read some of the
very poor answers that he had received
on this exam and one of the questions
was when was the paleolithic era and
somebody had answered a long long time
ago
well the same is the answer to how long
does it take to learn a language it
takes a long time it takes a long time
and so that's why it's so important that
two things really one that the process
be enjoyable and the second one is that
the process be efficient
so it takes a long time it's not three
weeks it's not three months it's longer
than that
in most cases
uh
so i looked up what the fsi the u.s
foreign service institute
says
and they say that for languages that are
close to english i'm assuming you're
starting from english but the idea is a
language that's similar to your own
they suggest 600 hours of class time
classroom time
some of the more difficult languages
like german which have cases and messy
things like that they suggest 900 hours
for the slavic languages amongst others
they suggest 1100 hours
and for asian languages they suggest
over 2 000 hours
of classroom time
classroom time
personally
i
don't look at it in terms of classroom
time i look at it in terms of time that
you spend with the language because
whether you're sitting in a classroom or
reading in the language or listening to
the language or studying in a book it's
the same it's time that you're spending
with the language in many cases the time
you spend away from the class
is more effective more efficient than
you time the time you spend in the class
not necessarily but very often so it's a
matter of how many hours do you need so
if i look at my own case
oh and the other issue is of course what
do you mean by learn a language so i
think my goal in learning a language is
to get to a level
where sort of i'm now you know i've
reached a plateau
where i can enjoy it i can enjoy reading
although there's words that i don't
understand and i can understand most of
what i hear on the radio i can enjoy a
movie i can go to a conversa get
involved in a conversation stumble a bit
make some mistakes but essentially
communicate i'm now at a level where i
can enjoy the language and continue to
improve
that's where i am in my russian
i think i reached that level after about
three years or so and now i've just been
continuing to enjoy the language listen
to things read things speak to people
and gradually improve
i think that with my check it will take
me a year to reach that level i've been
at it for six months and now i i can
read you know quite a lot i'm quite
surprised at how quickly it's gone
uh and uh you know i've discovered some
delightful things to listen to where
there are transcripts uh i've mentioned
before this uh tolkie chesky minolosti
extremely well done which i there's 800
uh items in this collection i'm going to
be enjoying that for quite a while
so within a year i should be there so if
we convert years to hours like let's say
that you have an hour and a half a day
to spend so let's just call that 500
hours
a year roughly so
again roughly on the fsi basis
a language that's reasonably close to
our own should take us a year to reach
that comfort level where we can converse
with difficulty can read can listen and
can grow in the language
uh
you know the german
you know somewhat more difficult
languages i can't remember what they had
on the list swahili or something
that's they said 900 hours so maybe it's
a year and a half maybe it's a year and
three quarters that's required uh
assuming that you're going to spend an
hour and a half a day or 500 hours a
year roughly and so therefore the really
difficult language well slavic languages
it might be two and a half years
uh which is kind of where i was i think
and um
the uh you know the asian languages
would be
two thousand hours so it might be a
total of four years on that basis
uh when i did chinese i was going five
hours a day
six i don't know how many hours i was
going full time
and
so
you know if i spent
just again if it's 300
if it's 300 uh days or 300 however many
days a good part of of a year 350
uh times five hours a day maybe i mean i
think i spent two thousand hours
uh one way or another and of course i've
worked at it since so i think that's
kind of the the sense
in other words i think you should try to
spend an hour and a half a day
if you spend an hour and a half a day
that's 500 hours roughly
uh a year this is all very rough
so on that basis a language that's
similar to your own like if you're
learning spanish as an english speaker
within a year you should be at a
comfortable level
uh in german maybe a year and a half
in russian
or jack two and a half years
and uh for an asian language maybe four
years on the basis of spending an hour
and a half a day if you can spend
three hours a day then you can reduce
that in half
so that's roughly
uh the time that it takes so that's a
long time i mean even the quickest
language is going to be a year now if
you know spanish obviously you're going
to learn portuguese or italian much more
quickly because they're even closer so
one year might be six months might be
three months if you are living in the
country then it's no longer an hour and
a half a day because in fact you're
surrounded by the language so it's
always a matter of the number of hours
that you have with the language so i'm
basing it on you're not living where the
language is spoken you have an hour and
a half a day on the basis of an hour and
a half a day
as i say reasonably
close languages a year more difficult
languages year and a half to two years
very difficult languages four years now
one year is a long time and i should
remind you that i said that you didn't
achieve perfection you're not at c1
speaking flawless uh uh whatever
language you're not uh there are still
words you don't know there's still
things you don't understand but you're
at a level where you are operating
comfortably
uh and therefore you can continue to
improve so in fact your target is to get
to the comfort level after one year but
then you may have to spend another year
uh continuing to improve it and to enjoy
it uh you know and this was my case with
with russia and i spent i mean it's now
been five years
but i kind of hit that level i think
after three and i've continued to enjoy
it
and uh and of course when i went to
russia for two weeks where i had
intensive exposure i i really improved
so
you know if you
once you hit that level of course you
got to do more talking to really you
know develop that fluency but whether
it's one year two years or four years
that's a relatively long period of time
it gets back to my first point about
doing more than one language at a time
you know one and a half hours a day if
you split that into two languages now
it's going to be twice as long to get
there in my opinion uh
so uh and so one year you know and then
continuing to work at the language two
years it's a major commitment so it's
important
that we enjoy what we're doing so we
gotta do things that we enjoy like i'm
just in seventh heaven having discovered
this check series because i know i'm
gonna enjoy it i just love listening to
it it's so well done
uh when i get beyond that when i improve
my vocabulary then i might be able to
read novels i find it still very
difficult to read novels there's just
too many words that i don't know
um so it's important to enjoy it and
it's important to be efficient so i mean
you've heard me long enough to know uh
what i think is efficient what i think
is efficient is to focus a lot of your
time on on listening and reading because
you can do it while you're doing other
stuff listening reading is is easy to do
it's a great place to to acquire
vocabulary and to to notice things if
you do things that help you notice like
underline or or highlight things or save
words and phrases in link or review your
free phrases
uh these are all efficient things to do
uh
grammar review as an adjunct to
this kind of top-down
big picture learning is efficient if the
grammar
learning becomes the major
goal
then i think you introduce some
inefficiencies because you're spending
too much time
not with the language per se
not exposing yourself to the language
but trying to study the bits and pieces
and i think that will delay your
learning and and might introduce some
level of frustration but other people
may have you know may have a different
perspective but whatever it is do
something that's efficient and do
something that's enjoyable
and be ready for a long haul
so that's
my best take on how long it takes to
learn the language i look forward to
your comments thank you